To experience living abroad
was always one of my dreams.
Because I was curious to learn about
new cultures, new ways of thinking.
I contacted several EU companies,
I got five replies back.
One of them was from
Velux in Denmark.
I worked there as an intern
assisting the social media department.
After five months,
I got a three-month contract.
After that I was given responsibility
for training the Baltic countries.
My life has changed dramatically
since I moved here.
Ive learnt new things,
the way I work, organise my time.
I identify a lot with the Nordic lifestyle
I like the tolerance
I like the culture of the people.
I like the order. I like the openness.
Another aspect which motivates me is
knowing that there are the conditions
and opportunities here that will
allow me to develop my career.
And on a personal level
its one of those experiences
in which you integrate
into a new culture.
Learn new languages.
Its not at all easy,
but its very gratifying and I will certainly
enjoy the benefits in the future.
Erasmus+ gives me an opportunity
to use my professional skills.
To grow as a person,
with a global mind set.
And launch my career.